A new device allows you to hear with your tongue.
Researchers at Colorado State University are developing the technology...
...which uses a bluetooth-enabled earpiece to detect sound...
..and then send the electrical impulses to a retainer...
...that wearers press against their tongue to hear.
They're currently mapping the nerves on the tongue...
...and they say it could take two to three months of wearing the device...
...to teach your brain to interpret the signals on your tongue as words or sounds.
Eventually, those with substantial hearing loss could use this...
...as a significantly simpler and less expensive alternative to cochlear implants.